tout homme bien portant est un malade
qui s'ignore écrivait jules renard une
évidence que le langage médical tel
qu'on le pratique est tel qu'on le
découvre dans roulette n'est pas près de
modifier vous allez voir dans l'opinion
sur rue devient pas bio que les gens
bien portants rencontre et on va les
trottoirs sont du câble aux malades
d'incompréhension devant le vocabulaire
de nos cher docteur et pharmaciens de
circulation monsieur oui à quelques
trucs de circulation au moment surtout
du des cars de ramassage des élèves qui
partent comment ça se passe eh bien il
ya un arrêt de la circulation en fin des
troubles c'est surtout place de la
république en face du prisunic pas si
vous avez remarqué alors la tachycardie
à votre avis qu'est ce que ça serait un
rapport capita harbi une province de la
picardie normandie picardie puisque vous
pouvez garder tant que kirby law torino
ça vous dit quelque chose qui ne me
parle pas de mécanique mécanique l'oto
rhino ça vous dit quelque chose
maintenant est ce qu'on n'a pas cette
voiture là non non non pas du tout
que pensez-vous des affections bénignes
madame personnel mais didier pas
beaucoup s'est pas montrée comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire je
n'aime pas beaucoup ces rencontres de
coin de rue c'est je vous disais je suis
pour le 30 à bord quelque chose de
solide
le scorbut scorbut excepté pour les
compétitions de haut niveau où on
s'intéresse à un score pour des matches
de football de rugby très important mise
à part ces grands matches ces grandes
rencontres je n'accorde pas d'importance
au but et au score c'est plutôt l'esprit
du jeu
et la qualité du sport qui m'intéresse
la voie buccale oui oui oui j'aime la
voie buccale
c'est à dire les chansons oui mais
classique la voie buccale mêleront
chanson classique chanson classique wii
la table était chanteur cédric elle
avait une voie buccale aux elle est
chantée au très haut
alors qu'est ce qu'un adjuvant monsieur
mais il ya les allures d adjuvants de
carrière les deux ans d'activité est ce
que c'est qu'un adjuvant et c'est un des
hauts lieux du souletin est au dessus de
sa région enfin quand je vous parle de
pathologies voyez ce que je veux dire
il s'agit de quoi alors non pas qu'ils
aient fait un pas que je sois à la pâte
pourquoi je vois bcg ça vous dit quelque
chose
oui qu'est ce que ça peut être bon chic
bon genre
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui présente bien par exemple
travaillent chez vous je sais pas je me
posais que kiki qui se serait aussi bien
patrick poivre d'arvor qu il ait bcg
alors bon chic bon genre voilà est-il
pénible à votre avis de garder des
séquelles
j'ai vu un peu ce que c'était il a gardé
des séquelles lui même je pense
effectivement
qu'est ce qui vous paraît pénible dans
le fait de garder des séquelles
garder les moutons en chef dehors et
puis c'est qu'elle sait qu'elle est sous
garde aurier de garde aurier pas de
séquelles tiendrait pas pourquoi
je ne sais pas si il ya de l'eau dans le
gaz comme vous l'affirmez dans votre
courrier comme va tenter de nous prouver
dans un instant gérard pas bio mais
notre spécialiste du sondage express au
coin de la rue c'est branché sur 2000
volts pour faire le va-et-vient micro à
la main et je vous jure que six
interlocuteurs si certains
interlocuteurs en tout cas vous paraître
disons entre guillemets à la masse
aucune des réponses n'a été prise de
force
si je vous parle de prise de force c'est
un peu dégueulasse à calais mais qui
viole une bronze à sydney ramos au poste
ils sont une lui apprend les reloge le
maire commence et j'en garde à vue
pendant huit jours et se relâcher après
il vient de me cambrioler comme ils
l'ont fait chez moi dans ma caravane
c'est dégueulasse être branché à la main
ça veut dire ça veut dire que ça circule
pas très bien maintenant
maintenant la petite tête c'est une
erreur je pense que être branché à l'âme
à souhait tout faire de l'élitisme dans
les deux cas c'est pas le
c'est parce qu'il convient quand je vous
parle du va-et-vient voyez ce que je
veux dire oui très bien oui qu'est ce
que c'est c'est des choses qu'on ne
parle pas comme ça dans la rue ces
choses intimes ça c'est pas en temps
quand je vous parle du va-et-vient
classique voyez ce que je veux dire oui
qu'est ce que c'est pour faire ça
traditionnellement je peux peut-être un
quart d'heure une demi-heure sur ça
voyez ce que je veux dire quand je parle
de va et vient qu'est ce que c'est
basset s'est classé que c'est normal
quoi
c'est à dire que pensez-vous du
va-et-vient jeu contre les homosexuels
le branchement vous voyez ce que c'est
alors il vaut mieux un branchement
individuel ou un branchement collectif
que pensez-vous du principe de la
conduite forcée
je suis ni pour ni contre seulement la
personne qui a fait un choix comme un
abbé par exemple ne peut pas se promener
facilement rue saint-denis ou aborder
des filles comme un agent de police ne
peut pas faire du vol à la tire ou se
chahuter dans la rue devant tout le
monde
voyez vous ce qu'est le tarif dégressif
monsieur dégressif c'est pour nous
enlever des graisses avaient tous là où
ça aux vêtements aux pantalons à la
verte sur tout ça dans quelques s'est
encastré c'est une ablation du prépuce
comment ça se fait voici tune acision
que ça avec souris avec un truc comme ça
est ce qu'il faut faire une saignée pour
encastrer puisque non voyez vous ce
qu'est la baguette électrique monsieur
oui vous avez j'ai déjà mangé cette
vague est qu'est ce que c'est c'est pas
croustillants comme la baguette au feu
de bois sa photo fait le même coup pour
paris y à quoi vous sert la terreur chez
vous bientôt à couper les colzas les
blés durs quel type de résistance ou
connaissent même
sur la résistance pendant la guerre 39
voyez vous ce qu'est le poteau
électrique oui qu'est ce que c'est si
pot-au-feu fait été cité et alors et
alors c'est formidable
oui c'est formidable en effet elle le
poteau électrique je crois qu'il ya rien
de vieux même si ses attaches un petit
peu à la casserole
on avait fait ce sondage parce qu'on
s'était rendu compte que dans une eau de
l'être nous que les spectateurs ne
comprenaient pas toujours ce qu'on leur
écrivait sur les devis voilà
la semaine dernière gérard pas bio dans
sa grande fresque intitulée au pignon
sur rue avait abordé le thème de
l'accord musical et de ses difficultés
se laver cela vous avez passionné vous
nous aviez téléphoner ça va donc
chercher le coupable est aujourd'hui
gérard a voulu sonder la france au sujet
d'un certain ludwig von b de son ami
jean sébastien de leur célèbre compères
wolfgang amadeus la mer de debussy ça
vous dit quelque chose c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas non plus d'accord mais elle
alors lui qui était là à mon avis cette
fête est un peintre non je pense et la
mer de debussy
non non je connais vraiment pas toute la
famille un parent lui qu'on entend
parler comme ça mais autrement le fait
qu'il ait fait des fugues jean sébastien
bach qui voudra apparaître malhonnête
malheur 1c family qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on peut dire c'est une molette et
d'avoir fait des fugues non mais la vie
privée des gens et les renier bricole
quelconque jean sébastien bach
ouais c'est un personne n'est à l'abri
de faire la walkyrie ça vous dit quelque
chose qu'ils étendent la botte avec
plusieurs types massoud en dise et puis
c'est très bon comment imaginez-vous le
boléro de ravel madame je l'imaginé on
peut le faire de plusieurs fois où on
peut le faire a arrondi
qui avait tourné avec un petit noeud ou
alors tout simplement avec des boutons
ce moment là on le fait un point tombe
avec la quitter poite
avez vous entendu parler d'othello
monsieur mes crayons non un peintre
othello bas je pense que c'est quand
même assez asséché non c'est bien
pratique d'avoir le courante à domicile
si je vous dit cosi fan tutte qu'est ce
que ça vous dit j'y connais rien du tout
alors que si je sais c'est à dire eh
bien c'est ali d'angle avec 1,9 de bois
est-ce que la périchole vous voyez ce
que c'est monsieur des percolateurs
cancer et qu'il marchait l'écrêtement
c'est un petit parc o latorre
électriques pour faire du café pressé
quoi avez vous entendu parler du mariage
de figaro madame
un regroupement social de entre le
figaro télé 7 jours l'europe
marie-claire jour avons parlé de la
truite de schubert
elle ne connaît pas expliqué moi ce que
c'est expliquez moi ce que c'est de ce
que vous connaissez dans ce domaine ou
alors rien du tout dans le poisson je
vous dis j'ai écrit pêcheurs que sont
les études de chopin votre avis bien je
crois le bateau je crois le baccalauréat
qui à cette époque était quelque chose
de formidable
vous comprenez qu'on parle des polonaise
de chopin non je suis pas d'accord là
dessus la vie privée des gens
c'est personnel c'est pas parce qu'il a
il a fait il a écrit ainsi de suite
qu'on doit s'occuper de la vie privée
des gens les trompettes d'aïda ça vous
dit quelque chose
non bambino d'accord pour bobino ça
c'est que cette chanson que je connaisse
dalida je peux vous en sorte un petit
morceau de vous lire bon bin au bambino
je sais bien que tu l'as d'or bambino et
gratte gratte sur commande ligne mon
petit bard guiniot ta musique est plus
joli que sous le ciel de l'italie mais
c'est pas les trompettes d'aïda annoncé
bambino messieurs 2 de dalida
vous savez c'est promis garantit rien
inventé tout ça c'est du fait main et ce
qui nous frappe très souvent c'est la
serviabilité nos interlocuteurs tout le
monde a envie de répondre même si on
répond un peu n'importe quoi
alors voilà
pense c'est que nous faisons
régulièrement à la chasse à la langue de
bois se dira ce vocabulaire souvent plus
compréhensible de l'administration mais
même des hommes politiques pardon
messieurs
mais il faut que vous sachiez que vos
administrés ne comprennent pas toujours
vous répondre vos réponses à leurs
lettres alors de grâce ne leur parlait
pas trop de corps constitués ou autre
terminologie de ce style regardez-le
insulte un tel que l'a observé gérard
pas bio grâce à ses opinions sur rue
c'est le terme que nous employons par
dérision les rues aujourd'hui étant
celle d'angers mais deux tours dans les
grands corps de l'état qu'est ce que
vous verriez monsieur mauroy pourquoi
parce qu'on voit toujours que toi que tu
es président quelque chose comme ça on
doit toujours très
beaucoup plus fort que les beaucoup plus
grand
que savez vous mademoiselle des corps
constitués c'est ce que les corps
constitués à votre avis qu'est ce que ce
serait ben c'est quand l'enfant
vaness on veut se pavanent est mais se
former l'embryon
comment imaginez-vous la dissolution de
la chambre l'a dit sur leurs serveurs
du mal à voir ce que vous voulez dire
par dissolution de la chambre si c'est
pour réparer un trou dans une chambre à
air
mais ce que j'en sais moi une fois qu'on
a trouvé le prouve il ya des petites
panthères ont gratté xiam ouai on met de
la colle et on une rustine je suis
simplement quand je vous parle des
relations extérieures vous voyez ce que
je veux vous dire vous parlez des digues
ont lâché des relations entre disons
dans un ménage ou quoi ou des relations
de jeunes avec une fille pourquoi votre
avis justement m je pense qu à partir du
moment où les mariés on doit avoir une
vie raisonnable que l'on doit faire un
couple uni et chacun doit apporter sa
contribution
le palais beaumont à nos productions
voyez ce que c'est
moi je vois ce que ça mais moi je crois
pas que ça mais j'en vois pas là de
whisky bière pas de moi quand je vous
parle de balayer
c'est le whisky toute manière comment
imaginez-vous un portefeuille de
ministre
le cheval est en cuir mais celui d'un
ministre est de mettre un crocodile
il est sorti mon crocodile ou en
pourquoi une matière nizon
coût plus noble qu'est celui d'un
ouvrier et puis il ya certainement
d'argent dedans enfin vous n'êtes pas
pour le changement de cabinet fréquents
non non quand s'est entretenu maintenu
je veux dire quand l'entretien et s'est
fréquemment ses dires bah c'est à dire
disons que ça soit propre camp soit
propre et puis alors de temps en temps
supérieure à celle de fonctionne plus ou
moins bien
l'affairé paraît aussi vous dire une
fois encore que nos opinions sur rue
sont rigoureusement authentique et que
nous n'avons aucune façon l'intention de
tourner en dérision qui que ce soit au
contraire nous sommes toujours frappé
par l'extrême gentillesse de nos
interlocuteurs
il est vrai que si l'on nous pose est à
nous mêmes une question aussi abrupte et
surprenante que celle déjà repas bio
comme ça au près d'une rue nous serions
peut-être bien embarrassé pour être la
nôtre
nous pouvons bien sûr madame lavergne
est clair et votre lanterne et pas plus
et voici donc grâce à gérard pas bio et
son micro trottoir tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur le sexe n'est
ce pas mon chien ou dit sans jamais oser
le demander
le détournement de mineurs qui
travaillent en dessous et l'autre qui
travaille aussi dans quel domaine
le faire c'est au dessus en général et
le mineur de fond en dessous qu'est ce
que c'est que l'insémination ses formes
et ses formes et des des curés des
jeunes purent et tout ça au séminaire
vous connaissez vous l'insémination
pourquoi je travaillais tous les partis
car et monsieur qu'est ce que c'est une
partie carrée ça peut être une partie
géométriques et à quatre faces égale
donc c'est une partie carrée par exemple
d'un élément on peut avoir une partie
karen partie rectangle une partie
triangulaire etes-vous monogame monsieur
non non je suppose qu'en maintenance et
là c'est la stéréo maintenant c'était se
dépasser soi mais qu'est ce que c'est
monogame face à ceux plus c'est long
aussi un système est ce que c'est alors
comme système c'est un système de
diffusion sur une seule bande
comment voyez-vous les échanges de
partenaires monsieur les échanges de
partenaires disons que sur les sur le
point de vue mondial disons que allez on
réussit quand ça va bien pour le gaz
peut-être lancé rien maintenant est-ce
que ça continuera
les pervers qu'en pensez vous je ne les
connais pas je connais les pères blancs
mais je connais pour les pervers alors
que seraient les pervers des perles
rouges ou des perles bleues j'en sais
rien du tout mon corps je ne connais que
les pères blancs une femme légère je
sais pas vous comptez 1 m 70 si vous
mettez 10 kg de noir êtes vous pour le
principe de la maison close complètement
non la maison bien isolée mur toi
fenêtres double vitrage moi je leur ai
posé chez moi on a gagné 25% de on a
fait une économie de 25 % de chauffage
êtes vous pour le ménage à trois madame
oui pourquoi pas parce que je dis que la
femme doit être libre c'est à dire pas
tout le temps étant la maison à faire le
ménage
c'est normal que le mari est si tout le
monde travaille on me dit que donc la
femme les chiens sa liberté comme tout
le monde
que connaissez-vous comme ce catalogue
alors je connais je connais des
préférences des 3 suisses et puis la
redoute
l'homosexualité ça ne vous dit rien
absolument pas non non en tant que les
si je veux homo je comprends qu'on s'en
sert pour la lessive enfin pour le
ménage quoi mais cette histoire de
d'homosexualité j'avoue que tout autre
en savon pourrait très bien en place et
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que c'est
votre avis c'est les juifs et sionistes
sioniste veut dire juif est alors
l'exhibitionnisme qu'est ce que ça
serait le retour des juifs en israël
nymphomane où vous voyez ce que ça
signifie monsieur qu'est ce que c'est
l'information
suivez l information alors parmi les
nymphomanes qui connaissait vos valeurs
si tron morosi
et puis après l'avoir d'arvor rihanna
forman je t'aime et je vois plus atteint
mais c'est pas parce qu'on est en ait
plus aucune info de 20 heures qu'on est
tous journalistes me charger à 21 micro
trottoir réalisé à nogent-le-rotrou au
puy et à béziers une autre lèvres
monsieur maurice rowland marignane dans
les bouches du rhône nous transmet un
reproche et des félicitations bravo pour
vos savoureuse au pignon sur rue nous
écrit-il mais pourquoi diable n'avez
vous jamais encore fait un sort au
langage des technocrates et politiciens
qui compliqua plaisir la langue
française pour faire semblant d'être
cultive au plan de la pensée rationnelle
nous avons donc dans votre sens monsieur
rolland à telle enseigne que gérard pas
bio notre spécialiste de la
communication à emprunter pour vous
l'infrastructure routière de l'hexagone
pour rallier nevers audace plaque
tournante de leur région respective et
dans le tissu urbain de ces deux sites
eiffarie l'attenté de désorienter les
carences linguistiques de ses
interlocuteurs et vous allez le voir au
niveau du comics et poêles et yvan
valable
vous n'êtes pas natif de l'hexagone
monsieur non je suis natif de lyon la
banlieue de lyon ce travail c'est quoi
la région du lion c'est pas l'hexagone
c'est le talent rhône mais l'hexagone
vous le mettez ou alors les natifs de
l'hexagone c'est à quel endroit
à votre avis l'hexagone qu'est ce que
c'est c'est donc deux côtés un quoi on
que du côté de côté oui vous êtes sur
wii qu'appelle-t-on le complexe
socioculturel monsieur mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a un complexe parce que il
ya l'impression qu'il ne connaît pas
cette chose et puis il a du mal à vivre
en société
l'impasse budgétaire ça vous dit quelque
chose j'habite à nevers un jour bien
entendu parler de sa vie est plus chère
jamais que j'avais à dire je n'ai jamais
entendu parler ces deux courses et
s'interpose militaire l'impasse
budgétaire
à votre avis avant ça soye dans les
nouveaux logements qui sont faits au
courrier voyez vous ce qu'est le
recyclage par exemple moi arrêter de
faire du vélo et puis on reprend des
années plus tard reprendre ce sport soit
pour son plaisir et vous vous avez été
recyclés vous avez fait du recyclage
aubin petit peu oui moi disons que j'ai
arrêté champs non mon âge pas j'en ai
toujours fait toujours un peu quoi de
quoi du vélo voyez-vous ce qui est un
champ de perception globale par exemple
oui bah il me semble que c'est
terrain qui est un terrain où il peut y
avoir des bêtes dessus des lois
même des fois je peux plantations pour
que ce soit ou le percepteur ceux
prélevés sur un impôt là dessus
qu'appelle-t-on les coordonnées de
quelqu'un quand quelqu'un met une super
à chemisier dans les mêmes coloris et
laisser ses coordonnées qu'est ce que
c'est déshabiller
voyez-vous ce qui est un stéréotype ou
alors c'est un type qui est branché car
walkman sur les oreilles d'écouter de la
musique à canal dans une oreille dans
l'autre outman sur la tête pourquoi
stéréotypes alors parce que c'est la
musique la musique stéréo
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle la masse
salariale madame c'est la masse des gens
qui sont pas propres qui n'achètent pas
de produits pour se laver
alors comme exemple de masse salariale
qu'est ce que vous avez
de plus en plus de pouls dans les écoles
de gens qui se laissent aller qui sont
par ac qui sont sales
vous dites ça pour moi non pas du tout
normalement quand j'entends pas rasé
j'entends qu'ils sont vraiment je mens
partie de la masse salariale
pas du tout non les gens qui sont
vraiment qu'ils sont vraiment sale quoi
là
deux personnes nous écrivent l'une des
vosges l'autre de belgique encore pour
nous commander le même micro trottoir
sur l'a7 il s'agit je lance d'ailleurs
si c'est pas que les guider par il
s'agit de deux étudiants françois de
grave de bruxelles brussels de et claude
martin de château qui veulent là et
l'autre obtenir un diplôme de sexologie
faisant une étude très sérieuse sur la
débauche et il voudrait faire précéder
la présentation de leur mémoire d'une
courte séquence vidéo dans l'esprit des
micro trottoirs de jura repas bio notre
licenciés etc sexualité vous chers dont
j'avais pas levé cette stabilisation et
comme je partais précisément belgique à
la réception wifi de votre lettre
monsieur de grâce je vous dédie donc ces
quelques au pignon sur rue alors claude
martin des vosges et vous même monsieur
deux graves selon la formule consacrée à
vos magnétoscopes
avez vous entendu parler d'inceste et
dans quelles circonstances monsieur dans
les boissons dans les bois sont bien
entendu parler d'inceste alors qu'est ce
que c'est que l'inceste morceaux de
citron ou un morceau d'orange
à votre avis l'hétérosexualité qu'est ce
que c'est bon je pense que l'hétéro
vient du des terres donc c'est se drogua
les terres ce s'envoyant en l'air en se
droguant et solitaire mais je vois vous
filmer mais même malade qu'est ce qu'ils
vont dire pourquoi suis infirmière je
fais le domicile et jamais vous n'avez
pratiques et l'hétérosexualité
homophiles qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bon au mot et film on ait comprendre le
mot
un homme ou d'un fils aussi au bout d'un
fil ce serait quoi l'on abat damas qu'il
décroche un téléphone peut être des cas
donc est ce que c'est votre avis
décamètre bon c'est certainement par et
ça me dit que 10 quelqu'un qui a dit
dans seulement 10 quarts des km ça veut
dire quelqu'un qui dit dans des cars
mais ça veut dire dit m donc un
personnage décadent c'était un caddie
dans le mot licencieux est ce que vous
connaissez
oui sedan a licencié
autrement dit qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
licencieux c'est un lieu où il n'y a pas
de toi je pense le doigt de toile au
dessus de la tête de la personne bon et
alayli
avec ce beau ya les rideaux bon qui
empêche justement dans le temps métier
ça pour les moustiques
on m'a dit vous m'avez dit que vous
n'auriez pas avec un licencieux oui je
n'ai pas de licence yeux réalisme en six
ans trouvez vous normal monsieur qu'une
femme fasse le trottoir non pas du tout
du moins pour le pavé est enfin là
disons qu'elle peut le ballet il parle
parle de construire quoi parle pas vu à
le faire qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
c'est pas normal parce qu'il ya des
travaux qui doivent être resté bien dans
le domaine des hommes c'est plus un
homme de faire le trottoir cas une femme
avez vous entendu parler madame de
déviation sexuelle
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya quarante ans
que je cours dit mais je connais des
déviations
mais pas ceux des villes qui s'appelle
sexuelle comment sexuelle qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire ça qu'on dit depuis très
longtemps et j'ai déjà vu beaucoup de
déviation par tous mais neuville
sexuelle c'est différent voyez-vous ce
qu'on appelle un adultère c'est qu'un
enfant quand les jeunes appel
s'adressant quand on grandit on dit que
et adultes et regardez vous par exemple
que la voir de simples des adultères
je suis adulte rcc vous qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire ça là bas qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un adulte un mois c'est ça
quand on grandit et devient du ter
autrement dit comme on dit là-bas refait
d'adultère voyez vous la différence
entre un ballet bleu et un valet rose
par exemple non moi je vois pas de
différence c'est le même qui soit rose
qui soit bleu qui soit russel mâle elle
même
il faut tout ça ménages principal c'est
que je sais faire le ménage
si je vous dis ça dont saad ben sadoun
c'est peut être ça dos à dos ses dépens
la grandeur du so nice au delà du sud où
lui du sceau d'eau va du sodium plutôt
du sodium ce dom alors sodome qu'est ce
que c'est c'est un assaut en métal donc
qui est prévu justement généralement
pour être employés par un homme à part
par une femme et un enfant
mais si je vous parle de ça dos à la
salle où ça dépend pas ce que ça donne
ça peut être ça ça dépote ça ça dépend
la cua la quantité la quantité de quoi
tout par rapport à quoi pour la grandeur
du sou du jour de quoi souder une lotus
ou d'hommes à la maison ça c'est un
enquêteur sadique dans ces deux radios
bien évidemment nous terminons par un
petit coup
dans notre abondant courrier le problème
des assurances revient beaucoup plus
souvent qu'à son tour et dans les
automobilistes se plaignent en général
que l'on ne respecte pas le contrat et
les assureurs eux estiment que c'est le
code de la route qui n'est pas toujours
respectée dans le premier cas nous
essayons d'intervenir auprès des
assureurs vous voyez dans cette émission
nous le faisons assez souvent et pour ce
qui est du code de la route
eh bien nous avons soumis ce petit
lexique proposé par gérard tableau pour
éviter les accidents de la circulation
trawick avec tous les chemins vicinaux
madame ans eh bien ces cantons c'est à
dire c'est pour aller contrôler aller
aux toilettes faire un brin de toilette
avant de passer à table et comment
nourrissent pas dire l'expression d'un
blessé on dit vicinaux andy cette
expression la commande destinée aux
chemins vicinaux vicinaux voilà on dit
c'était ondiste mollahs à la place pour
vouloir dire quoi pour vouloir dire vvc
quoi ewc on prend auriez-vous volontiers
les grands axes mode homme les prêter
oui à quelqu'un que je connaîtrai mais
autrement emprunter no pourquoi je ne
sais pas c'est mon tempérament comme ça
j'aime mieux prêter que d'emprunter
voyez ce que c'est que grands axes est
ce que c'est la rn13 ça vous dit quelque
chose
oui c'est une reine temps son mari était
le 14 ou hulu 13 qui le qui gouverner un
peuple quel peuple un peuple
apple je peux pas vraiment vous dire
dans quel pays bas restent ils sont en
france
comment faut-il s'y prendre pour
supprimer les points noirs de la
circulation
ben faut laisser faire la nature faut
laisser faire ça guérit tout seul
peut-être par mois voyez ce que je veux
dire quand je parle de points noirs de
la circulation
oui bah oui est ce que c'est c'est les
boutons c'est la circulation du sang
on parle beaucoup à certaines époques du
pc de ronnie qu'est ce que c'est que le
pc de ronnie monsieur à ces questions
ça c'était le ciel du parti communiste
n'ont à peu près voilà c'est un siège
qui est un renouveau du parti communiste
qui tardent souvent que pensez-vous des
bretelles d'accès et bien moi
personnellement je préfère la ceinture
mais ça c'est chacun tout un chacun moi
je trouve que la ceinture les plus
rapides que les bretelles et bretelles
vous dirai ça peut aller au tout aussi
vite si vous faites un côté l'autre sans
faire attention
ce serait quand même aussi vite dégagé
mais enfin le reste reste à voir le
résultat quoi la voie secondaire à votre
avis qu'est ce que c'est c'est ce qui
est derrière le chanteur
par exemple passer ce qui qui fait les
choeurs derrière qui reprend la voix du
chanteur qui fait quoi
ba qui fait la réserve lalala lalala
face à la voie secondaire
c'est ce que vous en pensez vous des
voies secondaires pas plutôt chanteur en
lui même je pense que c'est la voie
principale mais voilà la voie principale
qu'appelle-t-on le sens province-paris
basse et de paris il pense que les gens
de l'extérieur de paris qui sont qui
s'en fout
et puis que la province ils pensent que
c'est pas les gens de paris il s'en fout
parce qu'ils ont chacun leur sens de
leur sens leur sens de leur sens et leur
vous vous avez quoi le sens province
paris où le sens paris-province le sens
province paris c'est à dire c'est à dire
vous avez l'impression l'impression de
ne pas être comme ces de paris comment
ils sont sept paris mais il s'en fout
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle rouler au
pas monsieur la 1re les opa c'est
marcher un peu comme comme ça enfin fait
moins bruyant
alors là vous roulez repas
ap pourquoi roulant au pas alors c'est
vrai pâtes et les filles pour faire
épater les filles ensemble comment elle
en fait - world
voilà bah vous roulez drôlement bien au
pas merci monsieur et bravo à sadiola me
fais pas tu es ici et puis les garçons
puis tout le monde
et ben voilà c'est terminé c'est m
à l'abondante courriers étaient nombreux
ce mois pour poly micro-trottoir de
gérard tabiou une réflexion revient très
souvent au fil de vos pages c'est normal
que les gens ne sachent plus rien les
études ne sont plus ce qu'ils étaient de
mon temps on apprenait les départements
les préfectures et les sous-préfectures
pas de calais et ben oui ça a bien
changé pour se rendre compte à quel
point en cette période de grandes
migrations saisonnières monsieur pas bio
a voulu connaître sur l'eure là somme de
vos connaissances en faisant la manche
micro en main dans les rues de
montpellier
quand je vous parle de la somme en jeu
c'est pas moi je parle de lettre 10 ou
15 millons vous placeriez vous le stum
vous-même immobilier quand je vous parle
de l'anjou voyez ce que c'est qu'est ce
que ça peut être c'est à dire quand on
met le fusil il convient et puis qu'on
met la crosse contre l'ajout ne vais pas
l'air d'être su comment se sauver parce
que je n'ai jamais jamais jamais entendu
parler de l'anjou pourquoi parce que
dans les gens qui maniait des âmes des
services de santé manitoba la beuze
voyez ce que c'est que la meuse
oui ça fait du bien face il commet
jamais vu un pastis pourquoi la meuse
et c'est quoi la meuse elle a bien je
regarde une information presque tous les
jours jamais entendu parler de lyon
l'argent de la france pas loin de
saint-etienne n'a jamais jamais non je
connais très bien la région soutiennent
et de lyon vous avez jamais entendu
jamais non j'ai pas c'est même très
souvent est ce que vous en pensez vous
tous les goûts je pense que s'il y a des
lions je suis peut-être que d'être lâché
par une ménagerie où placeriez vous
l'aube l'aube mais disons que moi je le
placerais plutôt à l'est
c'est à dire les et la france l'a dit ou
fait dire ça c'est le soleil se lève à
l'est et donc il me semble que
logiquement le soleil loupes devrait
apparaître le plus tôt à l'est de la
france si je prends la france comme dans
une grande ville de l'aube une grande
ville de lomme je dirais strasbourg la
touraine ça vous dit quelque chose à
tours n 6 2 le jus de la belote
on en peut on dit en tout cas où tout
faux en tout cas on ne vit pas à trouver
la touraine ça n'existe pas que
pensez-vous du pas de calais je ne suis
pas au courant
vous me parlez du pas de calais je ne
sais pas qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
à votre avis non mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pas de calais à votre avis
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas de calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez par pas de
calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez vous même
par pas de calais mais moi j'ai entendu
moi j'essaie pour moi qui pose la
question c'est vous là oui je vous dis
pas de calais ce que vous voulez dire à
votre avis et le sancerrois alors ça
serait quoi zéro c'est à dire c'est
comme ça tu vois c'est à dire alors à
couper la tête à qui louis saez et à 1 à
d'autres il y en a un paquet mais bon
c'est devenu après ce day 3 jiangsu
c'est devenu la république alors le
sancerrois sur ce cas la république
ouais si je vous dis dijon dijon de gens
n'en dijon dijon 10 de gens je vous dis
dijon ça vous manque quelque chose dijon
je vous prie de m'excuser ont rejoint ce
foot dijon le long vous n'avez jamais
entendu dijon dijon ça vous dit jean
jean à moins que ce soit une ville à
moins que ce soit une évidemment sans
voix à moins que ce soit la vie la ville
disons de jeudi dont la gironde ça vous
dit quelque chose âgées rendre acquéreur
de c'est une femme très bien fait avec
des formes avantageuses 1 c'est vous
voyez
je vois pas du tout fait moi ou alors la
gironde c'est ici comme on dit le choix
je dois préciser quand même que dans ses
interlocuteurs il y avait un acteur
d'académie c'est pour vous dire ta bio
les pièges tellement ses interlocuteurs
il pose les questions un peu biaisé come
back certains seraient savoir il est
souvent très sympathiquement voilà c'est
dit
même très mal d longevilles mont d'or
dans le jura et royaliste et nous
commandent un micro trottoir ce qui
n'est pas incompatible pourquoi le
stress dans un pays si forte tradition
monarchique nous écrit-elle je m'étonne
parfois d'une méconnaissance aussi
grande de notre histoire de france que
les français vraiment ont la mémoire
courte
mieux vaut en rire ajoute ces dames avec
philosophie et c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
que gérard pas bio et constater de visu
l'étendue de notre méconnaissance sur le
sujet aussitôt écrit aussitôt fait
régulièrement jacques chirac fait porter
le chapeau aux attentes de faire porter
le chapeau habité rend l inverse
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est pas moi je vois très bien
mitterrand avec à chapeau oui c'est va
très bien et chirac
pourquoi pas avec un à une casquette oui
c'est va bien je trouve qu'il est bien
le style font porter ça voyez vous ce
qu'on appelle l' odeur de sainteté
monsieur bah c'est reconnaître une femme
qui est enceinte par son odeur qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais le gens pensent
que toute façon même à l'oeil je veux
dire il n'y a pas de problème on le voit
même avant que ça sent la salle et vous
toujours monsieur sur quel pied danser
sur sa dépendance
le tango par le pied droit un paso-doble
le pour faire hurler les pieds en même
temps si je peux faire une démonstration
s'il voulait la wii c'est pas difficile
on y va comme ça là vous voyez c'est moi
je suis pas très doué mois pour la cause
est culotté oui oui mais pourquoi vous
riez pas c'est une question qui surprend
quand même dans la rue et surtout de ce
temps là et pourquoi ça paraît évident
que des quileute et c'est à dire mais
qu'est ce vous voulez je vous dise moi
tout le monde je pense que tout le monde
est culotté le sens là c'est normal
culotté
je pensais quand même pas trouver
quelqu'un dans la rue ce matin qui me
pose ce genre de questions c'est-à-dire
basket vous culotté je pense que vous y
être que tout le monde y est moi je le
prouverai pas non plus à propos de nana
mouskouri que vous connaissez j'aimerais
vous parler du velouté de savoie
j'en ai déjà mangé il s'agit de ces
faits avec de la crème et des
champignons qui sont sans doute de la
savoie davy entendu parler du velouté de
savoie nana mouskouri
oui et qu'est ce que c'est c'était je
voulais dire c'est un potage c'est quand
on n'a pas de chance qu'on est dans de
beaux draps
ah bon dans de beaux draps oui ben moi
je préfère pas avoir de chance est dans
de beaux draps que dedans là dans la
croix quelques sous les ponts je préfère
encore être dans des draps de soie puis
pas avoir de chance que pensez vous des
gens qui passent la main madame n'aime
pas vous aimez pas quoi je n'aime pas ça
même dans le dos ou sur le bras je
n'aime pas qu'on me tripote donc si vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui passe la main
moi je refais une gifle que pensez vous
madame des gens qui font chou blanc
mais ces questions des biens jeudi gérer
mais les choux et les choux-fleurs ça
dure c'est à dire ces deux légumes là
principalement ça vous arrive au bout de
faire chou blanc quelques francs à
chaque fois que je fais cuire ces deux
légumes et comment faites vous alors
bien je les ai bouillante
je les plonge dans l'eau bouillante et
ensuite je les écoute et je les ai raf
et clients normalement
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle les feux de
la rampe monsieur oui qu'est ce que
c'est
gadola mal aux fesses dans quels cas ça
vous arrive des fois ça m'arrivait et
oui anne est un gamin
le général de gaulle vous connaissez
vous savez qu'il a connu un moment donné
la traversée du désert oui savait
également ce qu'elle a traversée du
désert oui parce que c'est un désert que
vous mais plusieurs motos qui risquent
leur vie et puis un jour c'est le bon
courage quand même parce que c'est pas
évident à faire ça soit ya pas mal de
l'accident ni des motos qui risquent
leur vie et le général de gaulle dans
tout ça la bonne et à verser du désert
est ce que c'est la traversée du désert
c'est un dessert
ça c'est du sable les piles other way a
que du sarde et puis beaucoup trop
niveau de ça et puis dans la vie du
général de gand enfin wa10 ont eu un peu
près parce que mon île il a quand même
encouragé les personnes pour faire ça
déjà parce que je ne connaîtrais pas
beaucoup il faudra déjà pour le général
de gaulle j'avais entendu parler dakar
du général de gaulle est pas tout dit
avec traversée du désert
oui c'est pareil dakar et puis alors le
général de gaulle qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fait lui ben je crois qu'il a essayé de
faire la même chose quoi essayer de
participer au niveau des pilotes je
faisais quoi lui bat lui et encres de
présenter comment ça se passait au
déroulement dans un hélicoptère
le général de gaulle au paris dakar et
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de traversée
du désert
oui voilà
madame rené clément et oui c'est la
quatrième de l'émission debitel hareng
thibault rue des âmes purgatoire la
jolie non nous écrit le 12 mars dernière
un nom bientôt comme le temps passe
n'est ce pas jacqueline mais aussi comme
vous pouvez le constater avec nous deux
il faut garder espoir ce n'est pas parce
que vous n'obtenez pas une réponse
immédiate qu'il faut vous tracasser bref
madame clément avait des problèmes de
copropriété elle n'entre pas dans les
détails ou plus exactement c'est la
seule chose dont elle nous paraît ce
propos les termes employés dans la
lettre qu'elle a reçues ratifié entériné
quorum quitus délégation pouvoir
déontologie rétorsion coercition avec
cela écrit-elle gérard pas bio c'est moi
bonjour madame ne pourrait-il faire un
micro trottoir au que si madame clément
le voici dix firat eefje madame
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle un train de
vie oui c'est un train ou c'est pas un
wagon de marchandises qui a pas de
légumes qu'on peut s'installer
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle le quitus
monsieur un produit qui tue les insectes
qu'est ce que ça signifie la déontologie
à votre avis ça signifie que en avant
que je sais pas on peut pas recevoir du
monde si on a parlé entre nous faut tout
ça au logis à la maison sur l'expression
vous connaissiez vous aviez entendu déjà
mesures de rétorsion oui j'avais entendu
oui mon beau frère qu'il y en ait qui
l'ont souhaité s à votre beau-frère
parler de mesures de rétorsion mais non
parce que c'est pourquoi votre
beau-frère parle est il de mesures de
rétorsion alors beaucoup le vêtement
tombe bien quand on dit le quorum par
exemple de quoi s'agit-il
ça a été le coup ce mélange de rome avec
eux c'est pas qu'une certaine qu'ils ne
sais pas à quoi avec certaines liquides
lesquels
les métiers de l'aude dingue fall a fait
oublier mais moi je peux faire leur home
secte d'avoir comme celle pour le quorum
non pour leurs hommes ou leurs hommes à
pour le quorum pour le rhum alors le
quorum on m'avait dit c'est quoi ces
eaux ni mis de l'eau où on mélange un
certain dit qu'ils ont dans le quorum
moi je peux faire et leurs hommes
quelques roms quelques robes à votre
avis un embargo qu'est ce que c'est
juste un bateau un bateau comme un
bateau qui peut arriver jusqu'ici la
voiture c'est tout la longueur d'ici là
c'est un petit bateau d'un petit bateau
mais qui porte beaucoup de monde sur ce
bateau un embargo
ben je pense que c'est la sciatique ce
qu'on appelle la sciatique et s'est
défendu toute la longueur des reins et
savent les rejoint
on appelle ça elle entérine et qu'est ce
que c'est mais entériné et quand on
entérine du foie gras ou du pâté de
lierre ou de la paix et tout est ce que
vous avez déjà entériné ou même le foie
gras est un gestionnaire qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un gestionnaire et pourquoi
un agent de police à nos homologues
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une personne
du manque d'eau seul dans quels domaines
alors pourquoi qui fait du théâtre du
théâtre ou alors malade mental je sais
pas
qu'appelle-t-on l'analogie c'est un
terme médical qui correspond à un tous
les maux dans le bas du dos comme les
hémorroïdes et et tout ce qui concerne
pourquoi analogie alors parce que ça
concerne ça vient du bonus qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une mise en demeure qu'on
l'aimé à l'intérieur quoi à l'intérieur
une maison et jaar pas bio et son
analogie tout dans la finesse cher
gérard en un peu honte au logis nous
quand ils reviennent le reportage
ces sujets dans l'émail poche à la
timbale maintenant
nous vous avions promis la semaine
dernière une suite au micro trottoir de
gérard pas bio sur les illustres
inconnus alors et bien la voici comment
se fait-il que vous ne connaissiez pas
les essais de montagne et parce que je
ne les connais pas mais je suis le tour
des scènes nationales tout je connais
arrive je connais ce thème ce que ça
peut être les essais de montagne à votre
avis un très bon joueur un joueur de
rugby
vous n'aviez pas entendu parler des eaux
des eaux mêlées de roger ikor alors
qu'est ce que ce serait d'après vous les
hommes et les deux roger ikor c'est un
mélange d'eau chaude et d'eau froide
dans quel but aux pratiques pour la
cuisine pour le nettoyage pour tous ont
le désert des tartares vous connaissez
le désert des tartares
these are we start 1 et le dessert oui
ça y est cité sainte
comment nécessaire c'est là y est servie
si on fait parler comme ça et quand je
vous dis la mort est mon métier j'ai
jamais vu un mot allah te reconnais vous
fait sympathique et c'est sabatier
bouger sabbatique à trouver le précieux
ou excuse
la mort est mon métier non ce n'est pas
notre métier c'est la vie entre les élus
les humains avec benoît a conduit à gaza
mais si je vous dis mon métier est là
elle est con comment la ville et qu'on
commençait de mort
on en paye si je vous dis la femme de 30
ans de balzac qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
la femme de 31 ans de balzac ça fait un
peu jeune pour balzac vu que à mon avis
ça doit être une question d'argent
je connais beaucoup de
de femme de 30 ans qui vont avec des
personnes de 55 à 56 1 entre 55 et 65
ans juste pour une question d'argent et
pourquoi vous venez de chat pour votre
balle jaune parce que balzac déjà est
une personnalité
ces personnes déjà riche de avoir entre
balzac
alors donc la femme de 30 ans si justin
les hauts de hurlevent ça vous dit
quelque chose
non non pas tellement donc est ce que
vous connaissez les vous ferrez chez
entendu par liszt compositeur
si je vous dis agatha christie a fait
dix petits [ __ ]
pourquoi est ce que c'est bien possible
que va se disent à la fois des quoi
hamel a fait dix petits [ __ ] les
horizons dans sa vie c'est la fête des
mères dans sa vie privée
vous aviez entendu parler le 25ème heure
de conte centre virgile géorgie n'ont
pas vraiment non et qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais 25 euros je sais pas
saisir facilement réalisable mais
réalisable de descendre les lotos de
travail 25 ans 39 35 qui est certain par
par semaine avez vous entendu parler de
la trilogie de marcel pagnol
je connais très peu mais enfin c'est
malheureux qu'il ait eu cette maladie
qui dont marcel pagnol qui lui quelle
maladie en prie logis qu'est ce que
c'est la trilogie mais voilà je sais pas
c'est ça votre avis
c'est une maladie terrible certainement
enfin le rouge et le noir ça vous dit
quelque chose
oui monsieur ça me dit quelque chose
pourquoi je fais deux tapisseries de
canova et je n'aime pas très souvent non
le rouge et le noir
le petit prince de saint-exupéry ça vous
dit quelque chose oui bien sûr michel
pâques c'est lui qui l'a chanté
comment est ce là lundi matin l'empereur
sa femme et les petits traits sont venus
chez moi pour me serrer la pince et
comme j'étais parti le petit prince
harry fils que nous reviendrons mars se
tient dès que j'ai pris
apparemment oui dit madame si je vous
dis qui josé mais est bien aimé moi
mais j'ai rarement plus n'a pas la
conscience tout à fait 33
vous allez voir
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle rouler au
pas monsieur rouler au pas c'est marcher
un peu comme comme ça enfin fait moins
bien
alors là vous rouler au pas
un peu pourquoi on ne doit on pas alors
c'est répéter les filles qu'appelle-t-on
un doctorat bohemen doctorat bon c'est
un docteur vous serez bon à la tête
d'une ville ou d'un pays
bon qui serait président la république
comme le docteur schweitzer pays alors
le docteur choisir ou au gabon je pense
et ça c'est un doctorat parce que c'est
le docteur schweitzer qui est le patron
ben oui et bon qui serait à la tête de
ce pays ou encore maintenant oui je
pense oui et c'est quel pays vous m'avez
dit le gabon à votre avis l'hexagone
qu'est ce que c'est c'est donc de coûter
un quoi un rond que du côté de côté oui
vous êtes sur wii comment imaginez-vous
le front national le front national bert
dégarnis sur le dessus bien en arrière
quelques rides une petite pour donner
l'air un peu soucieux un petit béret
puisqu elle je vois pas d'autre chose
le 14 juillet ça vous dit quelque chose
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le 14 juillet
ça a été la fin de la guerre 39 45
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le 14 juillet 4g en
fait
ce qui s'est passé à la bastille et des
avec les syndicats force au fo cgt tout
ça et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce jour
là ils ont manifesté pour avoir un
accord un accord de coin un accord avec
le patronat tout ça si je vous parle du
carré de l'hypothénuse
chais pas en auvergne un fromage ou vers
le carré de l'hypoténuse nuit à votre
avis un promeneur towers
je crois que non enfin quand je vous en
parle si on vous dit quelque chose quand
même
oui il va comme moi je vis dans l'eau
vers le militaire les jeudis
allergologues bas golog je pense que ça
se rapproche à google golog se rapproche
de gogol qui veut dire quoi
un peu bêtes et on le dit dans quelles
circonstances
quand on veut quelqu'un qui est qui et
pas parce réfuté en fait on dit quoi à
l'air gogol ou golog je suppose il
al'air golog ouais mais vous vous diriez
plutôt google google catalog oui qu'est
ce que c'est que la table de l'eau gary
c'est une table qui remplace
trente quatre musiciens des fois et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur sept tomes de
plusieurs définitions de chansons comme
me donner un exemple la la la la
contacts sont pour aulas je ne sais pas
moi c'est des joueurs comme ça quoi vous
allez le savoir quand même oui moi je
sais pas ce que j'en ai vu mais on en
avait vu ou des tables de logarithmes
surtout dans les orchestres qui servent
de tout ça ouais enfin pour moi que j'ai
vu il n'a peut-être pas roussir l'étape
de logarithmes peut-être les
mathématiques ou des trucs comme ça non
pour pas de table de lo green laurier
mat sur ces surtemps non non voyez vous
c'est que le bassin méditerranéen où il
voit sa muleta mais moi j'aime bien les
femmes me sens bien en chair bien dans
leur bien dans leur peau bien quand le
cul un peu gros voiliers eu le cul ça si
vous parlez suppose c'est pour employer
un mot trivial 6e et le bassin parisien
alors ce serait quoi
ben ça serait plutôt des femmes qui ont
les hanches plus minces votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'un oiseau migrateur
opérateurs c'est un enjeu qui va de pays
en pays
en même temps ils grattent la terre
prochaine aventure épique dans la terre
alors pourquoi migrateurs migrateurs
gratteur pour ce qui grattent la terre
et je me gratte
migrateurs migrateurs mon gratteur se
dire qu'ils grattent la terre et ils
admirateurs et la demie puis coeur et
pourquoi piqueur non plus car pour fêter
ça notre bon pour prendre la nourriture
dans la terre les gratteurs gratteur
c'est aussi pour d'autres sénateurs dans
la terre alors il est migrateurs voilà
biblique heures les u11 vicois
migrateurs aimé ficr dans un crime
qu'appelle-t-on le mobile je lui qui
peut vous dire leur opposition à quoi
alors à celui qui est mort qui peut pas
bouger et qui serait quoi lui la paix la
victime vers le mobile c'est le tueur
pourquoi et puisqu'il peut évoluer que
l'on sait moins si je vous dise à dos sa
daube à sa double c'est peut être ça
tout ça tout ça dépend la grandeur du so
nice au delà du seau d'eau du seau d'eau
pas du sodome plutôt du sodome se nomme
alors sodome qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un assaut en métal donc qui est prévu
justement généralement pour être
employés par un homme à part pas par une
femme départs à 9 un enfant mais si je
vous parle de ça dos alors ça donne ça
dépend pas ce que ça donne ça peut être
ça ça donne ça ça se demande à quoi la
quantité la quantité de quoi tout par
rapport à quoi
la grandeur du sou mais surtout quoi
nous sommes tus odom vous avez entendu
parler de cette expression la langue de
shakespeare ou et jada née mais pourquoi
dit-on la langue de shakespeare votre
avis bon je sais qu'ils vivent et rocky
ça j'espère qu'ils vont à vétroz
et alors alors on comprenait pas ce
qu'ils aiment en main et moi j'ai toussé
dirait presque du sco du premier
jusqu'au 6e et après j'ai arrêté
jusqu'au sixième livre lu le livre
jusqu'au sixième livre après j'ai arrêté
prost vieux qu'eux
il comprenait pas ce qu'il écrivait on
comparer parce qu'ils disaient parce
qu'à cause de sa longue et on comprenait
pas ce que l'enquêté comme un bleu un
peu bleus et tirait un peu nos lacs de
la cause de la boisson
ouais on peut plus et où d'autres
personnes qui buvaient moins un point ce
soir
si je vous dis chantons sous la pluie
labourage et pâturage vous dis chantons
sous la pluie
je ne sais pas chanter mais je sais
faire un poème labourage et pâturage sur
les mamelles est le fruit de la terre
cela vaut mieux faire l'amour que faire
la guerre et détruire tout le monde et
chantons sous la pluie
hélas les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
soumaré m'épouser sans se parler de
chantons sous la pluie il faut épouser
son site
non mais chantons sous la pluie ça vous
dit rien non il ne peut pas en ce moment
parce que il fait du temps gris yambuya
j'adore ça ne vous dit rien j'entre on
ne dit rien non mais vous irez de terre
dans l'espace vous donnera la
possibilité de créer en s'en va on s'en
va en sens quels documents accablants
moralité chers téléspectateurs si vous
apercevez l'ignoble barbu d'abord de
dans la rue avec un micro changer
immédiatement de trottoirs et puisque